foreign
Catherine's in Ocala Florida hi
Catherine how are you
thank you how are you better than we
deserve what's up
so I have a question
um my husband is currently enrolled for
fall semester down at UCF and we are
trying to cash flow College because that
is the one thing that we haven't taken
debt out on is a student loan so we're
trying to continue that um and my
question is would it be a
smart decision wise decision however you
want to State it
to sell our house
and rent for a couple months to get the
equity out of our house pay off
all of our debt and be able to cash flow
all of his college
how much do you owe on your house right
now and what's your monthly payment
um it's we owe 111
000 on our house and our monthly payment
right now
um with
homeowners insurance and all that stuff
is uh 1100.
okay and how much is the house worth
the house is worth right now
um comps in the area are going for 285.
I mean 1100 a month is a good payment if
you were going to rent somewhere how
much do you think rent's going to be
it would be
um roughly right now we're seeing about
1600 a month
um but the only reason why we thought
about doing the renting was because then
all of our credit cards have been paid
off our cars would be paid off
everything so then it would actually
lower our monthly expenses in that area
how much debt on those things
um total is 82
000. and and what do you owe on your
cars each
and thousand and then the other one we
owe 12.
and what's your husband studying
engineering
okay we have four semesters left
four semesters of engineering live and
what do you make
time I work full-time I am a night shift
nurse so the only question is because
you've got all these payments you can't
pay for tuition
that's what's jamming you up right
yeah I mean it's so what if I said
you're selling the wrong thing
what do you mean a 50 000 car does not
fit in this equation
correct so sell the stupid thing
I mean your payment's what 900 bucks
it's almost as much as your house
800.
um
yeah it's seven like 70. the only reason
why we're not is because we would then
be upside down with it
770 a month to put you through school
go buy a two thousand dollar car
um and let's you know clean out your
garage have a garage sale and start
knocking out some of these credit cards
but you have a car problems all you've
got
how much could you sell that car for
how much could I sell it for right now
it's going for about 45. who said
Kelley Blue Book for trade-in
um no for uh like Pride itself okay so
your 5K upside down
yes yeah so run down to the credit union
and get you a 7K loan buy you a two
thousand dollar car and get rid of fifty
thousand dollars worth of car payments
listen you're trading your home for this
stupid car bad trade
I think the only reason why we'd be
willing to do it listen you do whatever
you want to do but I just told you what
to do no I understand I understand yeah
you're gonna do whatever you wanna do
but this is what this is what I mean
there is no question the the fly in the
ointment here is not your house the
flying the ointment's not your income
the the flying the ointment the the the
thing that stands out when you give us
your situation that just stands out like
a sore thumb is this ridiculous car and
you are so in love with it yeah um yeah
that you're willing to sell your home
and move your children
for this stupid butt car that's what it
comes down to you need to get rid of
stupid by car well if you do that you've
got about 30 000 left which that's very
doable to pay that off well I don't even
have to worry about I mean you just cash
flow that and basically don't even
reduce it just pay minimum payments on
everything get your butt on a really
tight beans and rice budget get husband
through four only semesters left and
everybody work extra jobs no vacations
quit eating out tighten down your dad
gum budget you got an 1100 house
payments you can make it on that and
you're gonna be in great shape you're
gonna come out of this thing but you
know there's one thing standing your way
I might even sell the other one yeah I
mean that's a lot of car that's a lot of
car and then he's going to be an
engineer after all that so it's like
he's gonna have an engineering job she
makes 60k like y'all are going to be
he's working full-time right they got
the money you got the money to do this
you just no you're looking for an easy
way out don't do it please don't do it
you can do what you want to do but you
called here and the problem with calling
here is we're going to tell you what to
do